Hello everyone and welcome to the greatest four move game you will ever see now that is a pretty bold statement
and I've seen a lot of four move games and this is the one I enjoy the most and
It's not even a fabrication. The game was actually played in tournament play between two masters, but
Unfortunately, I've I've seen this game in a book
But I haven't been able to find it in the free database that I'm using who played it
so now hence the hoodie guys here and I know it may be better if I
Were to who this is since there are two hoodie guys, but it's extremely hot here and even one hoodie is pushing it
So without further ado, let's check it out
And yeah, sorry for no video yesterday, but I've been very busy preparing everything for the podcast with MVL
That's why I'm trying to get everything working and in order now, but yeah, this is one game
I always wanted to show you guys and the one that I
very
joyfully show people when I I
I'm with someone in a company and they enjoy chess and then they ask me like is there like a really cool quick game you
Can show me and then I show them this and they are of course very happy and impressed
so I know you guys are super popular with your friends in the bar in the library and
After showing this they're just gonna go through the roof
So without further ado, let's check it out. So white opened with d4 and the black replied with Knight to f6
So everything is you know perfectly normal and here white goes for the for the odd night the d2
But it's been played over
450 times in tournament play so it's not that weird of a move
you can use it to maybe surprise your opponents and here black replied with E 5 an early pawn sacrifice that
Double White's pawn structure and then and just go Knight g4 to recapture the pawn
So here white grab the pawn and we have Knight the g4 and here white is thinking okay
I have to doubled pawns on the e-file. I'm not interested in keeping them. I just want to continue development
He played h6 point being that now after Knight captures
You just want to continue developing night a3 for Bishop b2 or maybe c4 castles and so on
However, white is completely lost here and the black can win the game on the spot
So feel free to pause the video here and try to find the winning idea for black
And figure out if this is the greatest form of game ever played. Well, I'll give you a couple of seconds
So for those of you who were able to do it
Congratulations on completing the best ever form of game. And for those of you who just want to enjoy the show
It's not Queen to h4. A lot of people are a try Queen to h4 here. The problem is okay
You're threatening someone here, but after g3 and Queen H 60s white still cannot capture
But after the knight develops black no longer has any threats
So not not a not a solution
And also if you were thinking about Knight captures an f2 that's not going to work because after King captures Queen h4 check you can
Just block all the checks g3 and after a queen check series. We are gonna play e3 queen characters
Just Knight f3 and the black has no compensation for for the sacrifice piece
So the point is after h3 black wins by playing Knight the e3 and this is a game over
Now point is white queen is trapped and there's nothing you can do about it
So you're definitely losing the Queen and of course if you don't want to lose the Queen
And the capture denied then its Queen h4 check g3 and Queen captures and g3 checkmate
So after h3 and knights the e3
It was in this position that white resigned the game as there was nothing more to be done. So there it is four moves. I
really do hope you enjoyed it the player with the white piece is definitely didn't but I will try to
try to figure out which game this was as
I do know that
I've written in some book and it was maybe a book in miniature or something
But the the game actually happened in tournament play between chess masters. So really exciting stuff
I do also hope your friends at bar in the library. Enjoy it and yeah, I mean go go into the world and impress everyone
So I won a very short game. I don't usually do short games like this. But like I said, I make very very busy
making sure everything is properly set up for the podcast as I've bought a lot of equipment which I've never actually used the
The cloud lifter the the the new microphone. Well, there's like, uh a lot of equipment
So it took us a while to set everything up. But yeah, that's the I do. Hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank the Benjamin reaching
Bhupinder ostrich etre Scott Western Joshua GUI and the Jonathan air for a contribution to my channel. Thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual. You can check two of my previous videos serum. Thank you for watching and I will see you soon
Continuing the coverage of the morphe saga and whatever else happens in the chess world
So thank you all I will see you soon and have an excellent rest of your day